alvin bragg is the brand new elected
prosecutor in new york the problem is he
doesn't want to be a prosecutor he has a
hard time finding crimes he actually
wants to prosecute he will reluctantly
prosecute murder cases and public
corruption cases but he's not much
interested in armed robbery or burglary
or weapons cases or what he considers to
be petty crimes and even when he can be
bothered to prosecute he doesn't believe
in prison
so we have a prosecutor who doesn't like
prosecuting or punishing
crime i wonder honestly i wonder if he
might be happier as a defense attorney
or
maybe working for the editorial board at
the new york times we hear the phrase
threat to democracy
a lot
what would you call a prosecutor who
decides to ignore laws passed by
legislative bodies and eliminates the
role for police juries and judges
is that anti-democratic when one person
issues a memo obviating the entire
criminal code
why would the police arrest anyone who
isn't going to be prosecuted why should
the police risk their lives or risk
being sued to investigate crimes the
prosecutor will either reduce to
probation or dismiss outright
and this is just the most recent example
of these so-called progressive
prosecutors reforming a system they
don't even believe in
in houston texas people are being killed
by suspected killers out on bond
see how progressive you think this is
people accused of capital murder that is
murder for which you can be put to death
being released from jail pending trial
so they can go kill more people
does that sound progressive or
just insane
and it hurts the people most likely to
be victimized which is often communities
of color and those who don't live behind
gates or have security details
these hug a thug soft on crime policies
have real world consequences not only
are more people victimized and killed
but these prosecutors are trying to
change the law with a memo and that is
anti-democratic
it's no wonder houston and new york are
among a growing group of cities
experiencing more violent crime and i
hate to ruin the ending but when you let
violent people out on bond you will get
more violence
when you have fewer police and less
funding less prosecutions and no prison
time you're going to get more violent
crime
that does not sound very progressive to
me it actually sounds stupid and
dangerously so
my guess is a political strategy of
closing the schools but opening the
prisons is not going to work come
november
the question is how many people will be
victimized between now and then hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else